Food
Jobs
Development
Shipping
Tourism
New medicines,
innovation and technology
Clean, renewable energy
Our ocean offers all this and more.
This blue economy means hope and prosperity, for all.
The world's ocean economy is currently estimated at around 1.3 trillion euros.
By 2030 it is forecast to more than double.
Aquaculture,
offshore and ocean energy,
blue biotech,
and tourism –
all hold huge untapped capacity,
especially in developing countries.
Training and education will be key to success.
We need to equip a new generation with the necessary “blue skills”.
And we need investment in sustainable solutions.
Quick gains must be discarded in favour of long-term goals.
To responsibly use our shared resource, for both present and future generations.
To harvest the full potential of the Blue Economy in a smart, sustainable and inclusive way:
How will we reach across borders,
sectors
and disciplines
to make it reality?
How do we ensure that the blue economy doesn’t just work for us
but also for Our Ocean?